every single morning i have the same
simple morning routine
before i open my eyes in the morning you
know that space where you just kind of
like oh
i'm still alive i'm still here the first
thing i've trained myself to do is
when you go to change your life you
don't know how it's gonna turn out
wanna be happy live a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you have
michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the five
small routine changes that will deliver
extraordinary results in your life
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with change
number one build a habit of consistency
with mal robins
mom why are you making the bed why am i
making a bed
um well i'm making the bed
even though we're checking out of the
hotel this morning
because every single morning i have the
same simple morning
routine kit i get up on the alarm rings
i get moving i get my exercise clothes
on
i move my body i then journal do a brain
dump
i make my bed and even though we're
checking out of the hotel
um it's so important to keep to your
routine
because the key to changing your life
is change your daily habits
the way that you start to change the big
things is you change the small things
make tiny teeny teeny promises to
yourself
and then keep them so i have a promise
to wake up and get up for myself
for years and years and years i would
get up to make the school bus i would
get up for school i would get up because
my mom was telling me to i would get up
because i had to get to work i would get
up to get my kids to school
today i get out of bed when the alarm
rings for myself
i make the bed as a gift to myself
now normally when i'm home the gift is i
get to come back to a nicely made bed
and i have a beautiful place to lay down
and dream
it's also a gift because i start my day
by completing something
but it's also a gift even though i'm
checking out of this hotel this morning
because
i am building the foundation for all
change which is consistency
so here's how you put this into practice
think about what you want your morning
routine to be come up with just one
promise you're going to make yourself is
it going to be to get up in the alarm
rings is it going to be
to make your bed let's start with making
your bed tomorrow morning you're going
to wake up
and you're gonna make a promise that
you're gonna make your bed for yourself
do it every morning and you are building
the habit of consistency
and that habit of consistency is the
backbone to all change
change number two start your day with
gratitude with jay
shetty and oprah winfrey new challenges
require new skills even small
steps can create big change and i think
that's so important what you're saying
jay because everybody
always wants to do the big big big thing
and i'm
starting monday i'm going to do the i'm
going to run
i'm going to run five miles instead of
let me just run a half a mile let me
walk a half a mile
so let's talk about that what are some
of the small steps
that we can take now absolutely and i
i've been there to a person and know
what that feels like to be in that
position
and i believe we always have two choices
to escape or to elevate
and escape gives us instant
gratification as we all know and of
experience
and elevating gives us this lasting
greatness
we know that gratitude is powerful it
boosts our immune system it
brightens our mood but what i really
love about gratitude
is not just feeling it but expressing it
send that voice note
send that video send that message taking
that moment to
express gratitude make such a difference
in our life right now
and such a difference to that person
receiving it before i open my eyes in
the morning you know that
space where you just kind of like oh i'm
still alive i'm still here
the first thing i've trained myself to
do is to say thank you
for that because um
gratitude literally changes your
vibration it doesn't just
help you it changes your vibration would
you not agree
yeah one 100 and and what i love about
it and
oprah i've heard you speak about this
before and you know it's
discussed broadly around how what really
makes a difference with gratitude is
when it's deeply heartfelt
and it's really specific and so we all
know that we can really think about how
is this unique to me that's what has
such a great
impact change number three is develop a
good morning routine with grant cardone
is there any daily disciplines that you
have in your life daily routines
that you would attribute to your success
uh yeah i try to beat the sun up
i write my goals down every day and i
try to get i try to hit the gym
so i don't do it perfect every day sure
um
some things throw me off and and um
you know unfortunately i have a i i
created a lifestyle where where
some things are taking care for me that
that
that um most people don't have that that
option you know somebody drives the kids
to school
i don't have to do that that would
change everything if i had to do that
who knows maybe i need to maybe i need
to start driving the kids to school it
seems like a complete waste of time to
me
but i live two two minutes from my
office
uh so when i bounce out of here i gotta
go do a live a live stream on real
estate but
but uh yeah that that's the first three
things if i can get that done in the
morning man i know i'm gonna have a good
day yeah
pretty simple to beat the sun up make
sure you write down your goals
yeah make sure you take care of yourself
get the blood flow and get the heart
pumping yeah
and goes down fresh a new unit like in a
new unit of time like i write them down
today like i had never written them down
before nice
yeah that's um so so so simple on the
outside but so many people won't do
those those three i dare i dare
everybody listening here
to try to do it for 30 days in a row see
if you can even make seven hey man
how you doing buddy good how are you you
got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here change
number four start taking small
actions daily with jeff bezos everything
i've ever done
has started small amazon started
with a couple of people and
blue origin started with
people and uh the budget of blurring was
very very small now the budget of blue
origins
approaches a billion dollars a year and
next year it'll be more than a billion
dollars
so in amazon it literally was 10 people
today it's half a million people but you
you it's hard to remember for you guys
but for me it's like yesterday i was
driving the
packages to the post office myself and
um
hoping one day we could afford a
forklift and so
so for me i've seen small things get big
and it's part of this day one mentality
i like treating things as if if they're
small you know
amazon even though it is a large company
i wanted to have the heart and spirit of
a small one
and uh and so anyway that the day one
foundation
is going to be like that we'll we'll
we'll um
we'll wander a little bit too so i we
have some very specific ideas of what we
want to do
but i believe in the power of wandering
all of my
best decisions in business and in life
have been made with heart
intuition guts you know
not not
an um when you can make a decision with
analysis you should do so
but it turns out in life that your most
important decisions are always made with
instinct intuition taste heart
and change number five the last one
before very special bonus clip
is live in the moment with brendan
burchard
when you go to change your life you
don't know how it's going to turn out
you start the new diet is it going to
work is it not you don't know
you're going to change your career or
quit your job are you going to get a
better job
you don't know you're going to leave
that bad relationship to find someone
who really loves you cares for you
treats you well
are you going to find somebody better
you don't know
and that terrifies people uncertainty is
so scary because we might lose something
we like well what if i lose the job and
it was okay or lose the person she was
not so bad or
or i i lose that opportunity and it's
scary
to people but that's what your mind has
to be willing to wrap around deal with
your mind has to be able to say to
change your mind has to go i am cool
with the fact i'm not going to know what
the heck
is going on i'm going to go for it
anyway i'm going to
enter that dark cave i don't know if i'm
going to be eaten alive
i don't know if it's going to turn out
bad but i'm going to go in
i'm going to trust and believe in my
ability
to figure things out i don't know how
it's going to go
but i know i'm going to show up as the
best of who i am
to deal with that change your mind
must be allowing and saying i'm gonna
let go of everything i think i know
i'm gonna let go of everything i want it
to go like i'm gonna let go of my need
for
permission i'm gonna let go of my need
for perfection
and i'm just gonna try
and when you can get to that point when
you can say you know what
i'm cool with the fact i'm not gonna
know what the heck is going on on
because i haven't done it before i'm
gonna try even though i don't know how
it's gonna turn
out if you can get over that that's that
first sort of step into making longer
term
change for your life see i'm okay with
it i never know how things are going to
go
as many of you know i shoot this whole
youtube show this this
thing called the charge live my podcast
i do it
extemporaneous i don't know exactly how
it's gonna go i usually know the topic i
know maybe one or two points in my head
and i just go
but my mind when i first did that it was
terrified so i said no no i need
certainty i need certainty
i need notes i need a script i i need to
know exactly how it's going to go
and i thought you know what that's not
the charge life the charge life is good
with spontaneity
the charge life is good with being in
the moment the charge life
actually loves and draws energy
and power and vibrancy from
flow from being in the moment and
dancing with the moment
versus having everything needed to be
script in your life so have you not
changed because
your mind is saying i need everything to
be perfect and scripted out i need to
know all the exact steps in the future
if your mind is telling you that i
guarantee
you're not progressing growing or
achieving
at the rate that you could now i've got
a really special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you going
to do to take action on it
this week when you write down what day
what time and what place you're going to
take action on something you have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan and when you share your plan
and have public accountability it raises
your chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan to take action on it this week let
me know
put it down in the comments below most
people have not taken control of their
schedules
you wake up like an accident start
responding to other people's emergencies
and help other people build their dreams
instead of you building yours
it's time for a change you deserve
better and this video is going to show
you how
i think one of the biggest reasons why
so many entrepreneurs don't take enough
action is because when you get
motivated you don't do enough you feel
the motivation you feel the boldness
feel the confidence but you're not
taking enough action you're not doing
enough
i remember going to my first tony
robbins event this is before
uh i knew tony one on one before i did
the interview with him on my channel
i just went to see what would the event
be like
i've i've seen so many different videos
of so many different people
and i felt like you know what for most
people going to their event
it'd probably be the same as just
watching on youtube but for tony i felt
you know what i think his event might be
different
there's something that tells me by going
to his event it'll be different than
what i just see
on youtube through the content and so i
went and i went with my wife i went with
three people on my team i paid for
everybody to go out and went to our
first tony robbins event
and at the end of the last day if you've
never been to tony robbins event
it's on fire you're you're motivated
you're jumping you're dancing you're
hugging you're high-fiving you're
you're breaking through limits it's it's
amazing by the end of the last day
you see everybody in the streets you're
pouring out everybody's all pumped up
and energized like i'm going to do this
i'm going to do that
i remember one of the people that i
brought with me he's like yeah i'm going
to do all this stuff
he's like yelling and so fired up and
excited he's like what are you doing
evan
like i'm looking at my calendar because
this is why so many people fall off you
go to an event like that and then you
fall off because
you're not making it consistent success
is habits so whenever you decide to make
a change you have to
at least for me i look immediately to my
calendar so if my goal is now i want to
be a big youtuber
great when am i going to make videos
it's got to be in the calendar it's not
on the calendar it's not going to happen
and so anytime you want to make a
meaningful change you have to default to
thinking
what am i going to put into my calendar
because success is
habits and so it's great to be motivated
maybe these videos do it for you
maybe events maybe books podcasts
awesome you're getting it from somewhere
you feel motivated great show me in your
calendar where you are spending the time
to actually make the thing happen
otherwise you're just living off some
fumes
you know you get motivated for a day or
two feels amazing and then you fall back
down to normal
if you want that dream life you want
that next step for yourself
it's got to come from changing your
habits changing what's in your calendar
to make sure that what you say you want
out of life you're actually working
towards making that happen
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check the link right
here below me or if you want to know the
five
truths about habits that nobody
understands check the video right there
next to me
i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there